>> ROMAIN: Hi. My name is Romain. I'm an engineer
on the Android Project. And I'm here today
with Dianne and Jeff, also engineers on the
Android Project. And we want to show you a
couple of demos that demonstrate that you
can extend and replace existing key components
of the system because we believe that all
applications on Android systems are created
equal. So Dianne will start by showing an
application she wrote with the current public
SDK.
>> DIANNE: So one of the basic parts of a
phone user interface is picking ringtones.
Android comes with a fairly simple ring tone
picker. It goes and lets you pick between
a bunch of standard ringtones on the phone.
I wanted to write something and let you do
a lot more. So on this phone, I've installed
my application. Now, when you go and bring
up the ringtone picker, it lets me pick my
application to run, and when I select it here,
I see my more sophisticated user interface.
It does let you do a bunch of things. What
I'm going to do here is pick the music on
my phone. It shows me all the music on my
phone. I can pick one of these songs like
that, that sounds good, hit okay, and now
that's my new ring tone. Now, Jeff is going
to show you other things you need to do to
extend applications on the phone.
>> JEFF: Thanks, Dianne. One really cool thing
about Android is you can create shortcuts
on the desktop. But you can't create shortcuts
to everything, so I wrote Any Cut that lets
you create a shortcut to anything in the system.
To create a new shortcut with Any Cut, just
long press on the home screen, select Any
Cut. Here, you have a list of things you can
create shortcuts to. One of the most popular
ones is direct call. You should tap here,
and it launches contacts to get a list of
who you have phone numbers for. Select one,
let's say, Romain, click okay, and now your
call to Romain is just one tap away.
>> ROMAIN: Jeff just showed us how to add
exciting new features to existing applications,
and Dianne showed us how to replace simple
components on the system. But because we strongly
believe that all applications are created
equal, we even let you replace key components
of the system, for instance, the home screen.
I have here a phone in which I downloaded
a new home screen from the Android Markets.
You can see its page here. So now, when I
press the home key, I have the choice between
the old home and the new home screen. So because
I prefer the new one, I just click on it and
I'm presented with a new experience that I
prefer. So we hope that these demos demonstrated
that you can customize your user experience
by adding new features or replacing the existing
feature on Android.